russian troops are continuing their
advance on the ukrainian capital kia
satellite images appear to show a convoy
of military vehicles stretching more
than 60 kilometers just north of the
city the convoy includes hundreds of
armored vehicles tanks and artillery it
was reported to be about 25 kilometers
from kiev
the convoy appears far larger than in
similar satellite images taken a day
earlier air raid sirens have been heard
in the capital where city streets are
empty due to an ongoing curfew
on monday russian forces bombarded
ukraine's second biggest city kharkiv
destroying dozens of residential
buildings
ukraine authorities say at least nine
people have been killed in the ongoing
attack
[Music]
an onslaught in harkiev a city with 1.5
million residents
ukraine says russia targeted residential
buildings with volleys of rockets
people in a maternity ward forced to
flee to a bomb shelter
ukraine's president has condemned the
bombardment calling for it to be brought
before an international tribunal
today russian forces brutally attacked
kharkiv using rockets clearly a war
crime peaceful city peaceful residential
areas no military facilities dozens of
eyewitness records prove this was not a
mistake but the deliberate destruction
of people the russians knew where they
were shooting
moscow denies the accusations ever more
civilians are joining the fight to push
back russian troops from harkeef
i have six children at home and a wife
i'm from kharkiv
the day before yesterday i decided to
take up arms and protect my city
when i made my decision of course my
wife and my ten-year-old son cried
they tried to stop me from joining the
fighters but finally they understood
it's our land that we have to defend we
can't back down
ukraine is also inviting foreigners to
fight for the country as it braces for a
new phase in the war
let's bring in maria
adeva here a resident in kharkiv maria
thanks for being with us uh thanks for
joining us under these very difficult
circumstances how are things looking in
kharkiv right now
hello thank you for having me so today
the night was uh pretty calm uh in the
morning we've got reports that uh the
great challenge started so again this
morning two residential uh buildings
were destroyed by russian missile
systems great and then about 2 am here
i've heard a very loud explosion
very close to where i live so and uh
immediately it turned out that
a russian rocket got into the building
of the uh at kharkiv regional
administration the main administrative
building in kharki which is situated
just in the center of the city on the
main square across of the university and
near many residential buildings as well
no military object there at all
now we're just looking at some of the
pictures of that explosion you described
that would appear to have happened just
a short while ago is that right
yes it happened exactly almost
less than an hour ago and there was a
major explosion and
why this building is so symbolic is
because it has ukrainian flag on top of
it and already in 2014 russian forces
tried to get control over kharkiv and
they have put russian flag on that
building so and that's why you know this
this has a symbolic meaning also for
ukrainians and for putin who wants to
put kharkiv on the knees but it won't
happen but now what he is doing he is
actually having people here residents in
kharkiv as hostages because you know
under the
shelling that goes on every hour uh
there is no possibility for food supply
for medical supplies for any kind of
assistance
are you planning to stay in kharkiv
maria
yes i do plan to stay because this is my
home and i want to defend it as much as
i can so given any help that might be
needed to people and i don't know
volunteering and given medical aid
because you know our men are now
fighting on the streets with the russian
troops that that are around on the uh
outskirts of kharkiv so yesterday uh the
in the day before they were attacking
from the three sides and now they're
killing civilians we have the reports of
two dead deaths among children and that
is something horrible and that is why we
are here ready to fight to do to the
last end because we have no other option
it's our home and we want to defend it
what about
basic supplies do you have access to
essentials like food and water are
people there able to get by
well it's already running we're running
out of supplies so yesterday there were
big lines in front of the shops with a
supermarket small supermarkets and
bread kiosks because uh
already it's almost nuts and left and
you can only get a little from what is
left and the bread
you can buy only one loaf in for one
person so basically if the shelling
continues and it looks like that's what
putin has in mind uh so the the
town the city will be in blockade
because there will be no possibility for
food supplies and medical supply what is
more important and that is why we are
like on the edge of the humanitarian
crisis and they are asking international
humanitarian organizations to urgently
begin supplying uh
kharkiv and other cities under russian
attack with with what is needed with
essentials
how are people in kharkiv dealing with
this situation
are they able to find shelter in the
city to be safe
well we have metro underground is used
as a shelter so i know many families who
spend their days and nights with with
their children also
people hide in the basements and we have
especially
in the residential areas which are being
hit by russian great missile system
systematically so they spend their whole
days you know not going being able to
come out of the basement like sitting
there for days with the children locked
there and others who can fight with arms
they go to territorial defense units and
they know to go patrol the streets and
participate as much as they can in no
in pushing back uh russian troops out of
the city if when they try to
to come in
maria thank you very much that was maria
diaz a resident in kharkiv thanks for
talking with us
stay safe thank you
well for more let's cross over to our
correspondent fanny facia who it joins
us from
itsuki
funny tell us what the situation is like
where you are this morning
people are waking up to day number six
of this full-scale invasion we spent
with all of our neighbors
part of the night in the bunker as the
air raid sirens went off again people
are on edge they are nervous what's to
happen today and of course increasingly
concerned also about supply not just
food but very basics gas electricity
it's yeah it's much first but it's very
cold during the middle of winter in
ukraine and people are really wondering
just how long those supply chains can be
kept open so yes even though i'm in the
western part of ukraine that so far was
more or less
spared from a bigger attacks but there
are also military warehouses an
important military airport nearby
hanolinski that was shelled during the
past couple of days so people are very
much aware it's just a matter of time
unfortunately that they're also in this
town
are being threatened by by potential
artillery by potential missiles that we
have seen hit so many parts of ukraine
already residential areas we just heard
uh what's happening in kharkiv it's
really heart-wrenching
to know that it's it's it's it's not
just the bomb that fall down but with
those bombs entire chains of supply to
help those who've been hurt injured are
being made almost impossible to function
so very critical moments in ukraine also
here where i am right now in himalinsky
in western ukraine
now satellite images funny they appear
to show a convoy of military vehicles
stretching more than 60 kilometers long
just north of the city are people there
where you are aware of that and how if
so how are they dealing with this
knowledge
yes russian military is basically just
regrouping right now an attack on keith
is imminent and people are very much
aware of that in fact some of them have
started to prepare molotov cocktails
really it sounds very desperate in this
situation how do you confront the
russian military with with molotov
cocktails but at the same time if you
add up just how motivated people are in
key of those who still stay in that city
despite the threat that's so imminent
that also tells you that people are
ready to defend their country now
president zielenski decided yesterday to
release prisoners who are able to join
the military able to fight already a few
days ago he said anyone who is able to
hold an arm should get a gun so a lot of
guns have been issued here of course is
the concern also among local citizens
the things can go out of control in any
in many ways right now anarchy can take
over in many places so far the situation
in kiev is relatively calm there was few
sirens going off of the night but our
colleagues our local colleagues who are
still in the city are reporting that at
least they had a few hours of sleep
however they're very very nervous about
what's to happen today as this bulk of
russian troops is basically almost
encircling this this entire city and is
ready to strike
funny we i was just speaking to a
resident of hakeef which is under under
bombardment right now
and access to basic supplies like food
and water essential items is now
becoming very restricted what's the
situation with essential supplies where
you are
it's definitely better so far we just
heard in that report from kharkiv that
you basically are granted one a piece of
bread per individual it's not the case
here yet if you go into a supermarket
you'll still find very basic things
depending on also of course in which
municipality you are and how many
supermarkets are open the ones you've
been to yes we have seen those empty
shelves but we still had the impression
that at least the very basics can still
be guaranteed now this can change any
time of course if there are more attacks
be it on on surrendering
places in the area here not just the
military warehouses and the military air
base that i pointed out but if those uh
missiles that are coming actually all
the way from belarus uh to here where we
are right now when they are going to
destroy very critical infrastructure
that is needed to actually keep those
supply chains open so people are worried
even the ones who still get their bread
and get their even their vegetables in
the supermarket today just how long
that's going to happen as a result a lot
of people stock up on food and panic
starts to set in
and also people who are here in this
well so far was a relatively calm town
are packing up and they are leaving
they're trying to leave across the
border to romania and try to bring their
their families to safety
is there any hope fannie among the
people you were talking to there that a
diplomatic solution could be found in
this conflict because we do have ukraine
and russia finally sitting down at the
negotiating table
actually we're talking about this very
question with our neighbors yesterday in
the bunker and they said they would like
to have this glimpse of hope but at the
same time if this country is being
bombed while so-called negotiation take
place they don't really hope that's
going to be anytime soon now what we do
know of course that after this
yeah meeting between russia and
ukrainian delegation that ended without
a breakthrough so far
we know that the second round is
supposed to take place it's unclear when
but the people here on the ground are
actually calling on the allies and the
western allies to say please help us
please us in terms of military please
help us in terms of humanitarian aid and
please help us to bring an end to
to this to this war to this full-scale
invasion so people don't really have a
high hopes when it comes to negotiations
with the aggressor as they say
via belarus they rather put their faith
into uh whatever is to come from the
west
funny thank you very much that was our
correspondent funny faculty in western
ukraine
well the first emergency united nations
general assembly session in decades
opened with a minute's silence for those
killed in ukraine more than a hundred
nations have signed up to speak out
about ukraine's invasion at the session
which continues today un secretary
general antonio guterres spoke of a
moment of truth for humanity
a minute of silence
to mourn those killed in russia's
days-long ground and air attack on
ukraine
then nation after nation took to the
podium condemning president vladimir
putin's war and his decision to put
russia's nuclear forces on high alert
excellency
we are facing a tragedy for ukraine but
also a major regional crisis with
potentially disastrous implications for
us all
yesterday russian nuclear forces were
put on high alert
this is a chilling development
the mere idea of a nuclear conflict is
simply inconceivable
a war of this scale seemed inconceivable
just days before the invasion ukraine's
envoy to the un spoke passionately about
civilian suffering in his country and
warned that global peace is at stake
if ukraine does not survive intention
survive international peace will not
survive
if ukraine does not survive the united
nations will not survive have no
illusions
russia's envoy accused the media of
creating fake news about what putin
calls a special military operation and
blamed ukraine for causing the war by
mistreating russian supporters and
breakaway regions
this definitely persuaded us that we
could no longer ignore the suffering to
people in donbas the leaders of
breakaway regions turn to us for
military support monday's emergency
session of the un general assembly lays
the groundwork for a resolution members
will vote on later in the week in part
it demands russia immediately stops its
attack and withdraws all troops from
ukraine
the international criminal court in the
hague will launch an investigation on
the situation in ukraine following
russia's invasion the chief prosecutor
kareem khan says there is reasonable
basis to believe alleged war crimes and
crimes against humanity have been
committed in the attack
neither of the two countries uh russia
nor ukraine are members of the icc but
ukraine has accepted its jurisdiction in
the past
russia for its part does not recognize
the court's authority at all
our chief political correspondent
melinda crane joins us in this studio
melinda i know that you covered the
balkan wars and the ensuing war crimes
trials i also know that you studied
international law and are very well
versed on this subject do you think
we could see an indictment in the hague
against russian president vladimir putin
or the officers who are in fact
committing uh crimes uh on his orders uh
normally you begin with those who are on
the ground and then follow the chain of
command upward and yes i do if we look
for example at these latest reports of
the probable use of cluster bombs in
hakief or if we look at a cluster bomb
confirmed on february 25th in against a
kindergarten and nursery in the town of
arkartica
sumi oblast then and that's been
confirmed by amnesty then these are
absolutely uh violations uh that could
be pursued by the international criminal
court but there are others as well for
example uh russian forces have boasted
of eliminating combatants uh in some of
the places they've fought including at
the airport outside of kiev you don't
simply eliminate combatants you are
required by the laws of war by the hague
conventions to take them prisoner and
give them certain kinds of treatment so
there is real reason to believe that war
crimes are being committed here
at the same time ukraine has also gone
to the international court of justice on
another matter namely the violation of
its territorial integrity the law on
wars of aggression is somewhat more
unclear that wouldn't probably be a
charge that we'd see in the
international criminal court but i think
that the prosecutor's decision to look
into this is absolutely justified and
what it means
as i say you try to chase that
that chain of command right back up to
vladimir putin and then ultimately he is
further isolated he can no longer travel
if he ever leaves his country he will be
subject to arrest that's the objective
and as we know it happened to milosevic
in the balkan
there's been a lot of discussion about
whether or not the international
community should or could intervene
militarily in some form
of course ukraine is not a nato member
nato at this point says it has no
intention of intervening but we did see
nato intervene in the balkan wars
could there come a point melinda do you
think when nato might decide that the
suffering of the people the war crimes
being committed are so severe that it
needs to intervene here
strictly on the point of law
essentially there are two provisions
under which
force can be used one is the right to
self-defense which includes collective
self-defense that would obviously be an
easier matter if ukraine were in fact a
member of nato ukraine is not a member
of nato therefore it becomes a little
bit more difficult the clearest path
would be a u.n security council
resolution we're not going to get that
that by the way was what happened
when iraq invaded kuwait as you will
remember the u.n security council
empowered other countries essentially to
help get iraq out of kuwait if it didn't
leave voluntarily that is a clearer
legal position but terry that's the law
side the other side of course is simply
uh pragmatism reality the adversary here
is a nuclear-armed power i cannot
imagine that nato would go up against uh
russia under these circumstances when
ukraine is not a member of nato the
legal situation is somewhat hazy and the
reality
is obviously very problematic
okay so that's the uh that's the legal
aspect with respect to nato and the
international criminal court
let's talk about the european union we
know that
ukraine would like to be a member of
both nato and the european union
on monday we saw the ukrainian president
sign a formal application for eu
membership how is that likely to be
received in brussels it's quite
interesting uh ursula fond de la and the
commission president has
gone uh straight out into the to in in
public and said she supports this
membership uh and in fact yesterday uh
foreign minister bairbach here in
germany had a visit from her counterpart
from slovenia and he also gave a strong
plea for this application to be
considered
obviously the idea here is if you can't
bring ukraine into the nato fold could
you maybe at least bring them into the
european union uh fold which would
afford some kind of protection in fact
more protection now than we would have
thought uh possible previously the eu is
offering ukraine 500 million in weapons
support for the first time so
that's quite an interesting aspect as to
why this
is clearly of interest to ukraine on the
other hand the path to eu membership is
a long path and it involves some of the
same hurdles that ukraine faces
vis-a-vis nato countries that want to
join the eu have to show that they have
stable transparent non-corrupt
governments that has been a
long-standing problem in ukraine
definitely improvements in that area but
there's still a long way to go so this
is not a path that would happen quickly
and germany's foreign minister did say
that yesterday
thank you very much and i'm sure we'll
be talking to you further throughout the
day our chief political correspondent
melinda crane
now to some of the other headlines
related to the war in ukraine
the united states is expelling 12
russian u.n diplomats accusing them of
being spies russia's u.n ambassador
vasily nevins
told a session of the united of the
security council about the move calling
it a hostile step he later refused to
specify whether he was among those told
to leave
turkey's president recep tayyip erdogan
says he'll restrict russian warships
from key waterways to the black sea a
1936 treaty gives turkey the right to
stop military vessels from passing
through the dardanelles and bosphorous
straits during wartime
several russian ships have recently
passed through the straits into the
black sea which also borders ukraine
western sanctions triggered by the
invasion of ukraine have sent the ruble
plummeting the currency fell 30 in value
after moves to cut off russia's access
to foreign exchange
russians scrambled to withdraw money
from cash machines
russia's central bank doubled its key
interest rate to prop up the currency
in a further escalation of tensions
president vladimir put vladimir putin
placed his country's nuclear forces on
high alert on sunday before the invasion
of ukraine began putin ordered military
drills involving his arsenal of
nuclear-capable missiles he oversaw them
personally with the leader of belarus
alexander lukashenko
kremlin said those exercises were part
of regular training and denied they
signaled an escalation
but russia invaded ukraine on thursday
putin blamed aggressive statements from
nato for the change in posture
top officials from leading nato
countries have been making aggressive
statements
that is why i've ordered the defense
minister and chief of the general staff
to put our deterrent forces on high
combat alert
let's bring in pavel podvick here he is
considered a leading expert on russia's
nuclear arsenal and he's independent
analyst based in geneva thanks for being
with us pavel so putin has put his
nuclear deterrent on high alert what
does that mean in practical terms
well
first thing we need to keep in mind is
that the russian nuclear forces as well
as other nuclear forces are constantly
on high alert
more than a
thousand warheads are deployed on
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
they are uh in very high readiness
uh what uh this move that was announced
on
sunday
meant
is was not increasing the number of
missiles or submarines out there
apparently
it was
the united states has not detected any
movements of
forces that would indicate that what it
appears to mean uh is that the uh
it was a signal to
the united states
first and foremost
that
russian forces
are have taken steps to protect uh
themselves from
a potential attack and the uh the signal
is basically don't don't even try uh
don't even think about attacking russia
what is russia's nuclear capability we
know that russia has many nuclear
weapons but how dangerous how dangerous
is it with these weapons
well
it's uh
it's quite dangerous uh as i said uh the
uh
around thousand warheads on uh
intercontinental ballistic missiles only
there are submarines there are bombers
uh overall uh russia
is one of two
major nuclear powers
it has more than 4 000 warheads in its
arsenal
as the united states uh actually does
uh and uh
it is uh
something to
consider and that's apparently that's
the calculation uh in the kremlin that
people will
be
taking
these signals seriously and
would not interfere
on behalf of ukraine
now you are an expert on russia's
nuclear arsenal do you believe that
president vladimir putin would actually
order a nuclear missile strike if he
felt threatened
[Music]
well
i certainly hope that he would not
uh but the uh the problem is that uh and
what i find very problematic is that uh
he uh explicitly uh brought
nuclear weapons into this conflict even
even as a signal even in at the
rhetorical level
and uh
a conflict like that uh very complex uh
could involve uh very unexpected
developments and
now that we know that
russia
indicated or said actually explicitly
that
it does consider nuclear weapons to be a
factor
things can go in many uh wrong ways
i i think it was uh good that the united
states did not react uh in a similar
fashion the united states did not
indicate that they would want uh to
bring its forces to higher alert
uh and it was good to see that the u.n
uh general assembly uh session yesterday
a lot of states
called that move that
introduction of nuclear weapons they
called it uh unacceptable and
irresponsible
and i think that should be uh the
message the reaction should be that
nuclear weapons should not belong to to
any conflict in fact but definitely they
should not be anywhere clear
of this conflict
okay here we are with russia having
invaded a sovereign country it is now at
least sending a rhetorical signal about
its nuclear weapons
what can be done
by the west in this situation to
de-escalate uh what's happening and
perhaps bring about a a some sort of
solution that doesn't involve further
bloodshed
well that's uh that's a very uh
difficult uh problem uh and uh i i think
uh since uh as you
said correctly uh uh we are dealing with
the nuclear nuclear armed states here
uh it's uh everybody should uh try it
very carefully uh because
there are as i said there are
possible unexpected and unpredictable
developments
here and uh
we we would think that a use of nuclear
weapons is uh unconceivable
but then this whole invasion was
inconceivable just about a week ago
so uh
i think the message should be uh very
firm and clear as i said and not just
from the west but from other countries
as well
that it is as i said it's irresponsible
and unacceptable
uh to uh wave your nuclear weapons
around the way that russia did
pavel podvik an expert on russia's
nuclear capabilities thank you very much
for talking with us